Financial knowledge is important to
everyone
here are three must read books to gain
Financial knowledge
one the intelligent investor by Benjamin
Graham widely considered to be the Bible
of value investing and a must read for
anyone interested in long-term
fundamental analysis of stocks and bonds
two The Total Money Makeover by Dave
Ramsey a personal finance classic that
provides a step-by-step plan for getting
out of debt building an emergency fund
and investing for the future
three Rich Dad Poor Dad by Robert
Kiyosaki a best-selling personal finance
book that advocates for financial
education and the importance of building
passive income streams through real
estate and other Investments
thank you for watching